have you ever seen someone who was like
you know fairly good yeah but then all
of a sudden something clicks and they
become great i've seen someone who is
fairly good and all of a sudden they
become worse i see that every day in the
mirror
yes that's a great question ali wong uh
she jumped to the next level in terms of
just like connecting connecting how do
you think that happens just repetition
and practice it's almost like uh like
working out where like eventually it's
just gonna it's just gonna be muscle you
know and i think that's what we're
seeing now yeah that's a really good
question that's kind of exciting but the
best book i ever read on that was like
steve martin's book like he wasn't like
a natural comic he said he had a he
describes how he worked at it he got
better and better and better you got to
read that book you know steve morton is
a guy who like you know i put him in
albert books as the guys who like
they're the crossover guys where they
went from like you know uh
performance to like just being able to
like activate this other whole thing of
directing and writing and all that kind
of stuff i'm not talented that way but i
i really appreciate that that where they
kind of hit the wall and they're like
you know what i i no longer i am being
creative uh in live performance so i'm
gonna go and do movies and things yeah
it's amazing and then you got guys like
judd apatow who is an amazing director
and i see him at the comedy clubs he's
working on his act he is great
he really is interesting he really is
good